even cory booker
with his bizarre rants and his spartacus
moments and his tears of anger and wrath
even joe biden with his completely
nonsensical stammerings in his brain
made of pudding neither of them are my
least favorite democrats running the
country right now
my actual least favorite and this has
been true for two years this has been
true going back to the democrat
primaries my least favorite one
is pete buttigieg and i feel
vindicated in my distaste for pete
buddha judge because buddha judge just
went on with the cackling hands on the
view and he was asked what he thinks
about the florida law parental rights
and education the law which says that
kindergarten teachers can't trans the
five-year-olds and pete buddha judge
said that he believes that the law
will kill
children
he's been a vocal critic of what's going
on in my state of florida when the with
the so-called don't say gay
law now um which
he says will kill kids do you agree
and you know as a politician because
this this
strikes you as you know your husband is
a teacher
you are uh obviously lgbtq yourself and
you are now a parent yeah
so how do you feel yeah he's right and
and i think every law to be judged for
the effect it's going to have on real
people in real life and i i get the
political reasons why they're doing this
by the way some of those political
reasons
they don't have a plan on anything else
right i mean they they don't have a plan
on dealing with inflation or or dealing
with with gas prices or dealing with the
issues we can't get home insurance in
florida
hold on hold on i'm going to get i i'll
get to the main point that pete budaj is
making which is extremely stupid but
first i've got to get to that the second
point he says the reason they're the
reason they're preventing us from
lopping off the genitals of
five-year-olds is because they don't
have a plan on gas
you know they don't have a plan on
inflation in the economy all of that was
going great when we were running the
show dum-dum and then you guys got in
charge and all of a sudden inflation
goes through the roof and hits a 40-year
high and and gas prices also hit
all-time record highs and we know
exactly why that happened by the way if
that happened because you shut down oil
pipelines you shut down oil production
in america then you gave vladimir putin
a pipeline you okayed the pipeline that
we republicans had shut down the
pipeline which zolensky says was the
cause of the war that was the immediate
cause of the russian invasion because
biden lifted the sanctions off the oil
pipeline and now you've got a major war
in ukraine which is very important not
only to europe but to to energy
production around the world and now gas
prices are through the roof so
and now you have the audacity
to look at us and say you don't have a
plan here's my plan don't give putin a
pipeline give americans a pipeline stop
printing money like drunken sailors and
and
just do what we were doing under trump
when everything was working
that's the first part that's the i guess
that's the second stupid thing that
buddha judge said but then to his main
point
he says that the law in florida which
prevents you from
introducing five-year-olds to
transgenderism in public school
classrooms
the law in florida
which stops teachers from encouraging
five-year-old kids to take cross-sex
hormones and lop off their genitals he
says that law is going to kill kids
pete buddha judge who supports abortion
so
so abortion which literally kills kids
that does not kill kids according to
buddhijudge
letting five-year-olds keep their
genitals and not encouraging them to
take cross-sex hormones
that will kill kids
i
didn't think i could like pete
butterjudge less than i already did
but i do frankly i liked him better when
he was on maternity leave do you
remember buddha judge becomes the
transportation secretary
we've got a major supply chain crisis
and everyone started criticizing buddha
judge because he was nowhere to be found
because he was on maternity leave pete
buddha judge was
out i guess recovering from his
c-section maybe he was chest feeding i'm
not sure exactly what he was doing but
buddha judge was out for months
not doing his job as a cabinet secretary
and i actually liked him better then
because then he wasn't running his mouth
he was just living life as a private
citizen which is where he should be
now he's coming out and saying we need
to trans the kids and he does it in this
way to make it sound like we're the
unreasonable ones
the vast majority of americans who
support the florida law we're the
unreasonable you know these guys it's
just for political reasons and look i
get it i get their political reasons but
we have to we have to trans the kids or
or that will kill them
and this is what they say by the way
this is you know how desperate the
democrats are on this they've got no
argument whatsoever for transiting the
kids because it's just an absolute
it's the most outrageous thing they've
done since they legalized the national
national killing of little babies in the
womb
but they've got no answer here so they
say well if you don't let us trans the
kids they're going to kill themselves
this is what this is what abusive
girlfriends and boyfriends do if you
leave me i'm going to kill myself if you
do anything i'm going to kill this it's
the exact same tactic if you don't let
us trans the kids they're going to kill
themselves that's not true first of all
there's no evidence
there's no social scientific evidence
for the claims that they're making that
if we don't put kids
if we don't allow people to chop off
parts of their bodies and mutilate
themselves that they're they're going to
kill themselves
the
rates of suicide depression anxiety and
all the rest of it
in post-op and pre-op transgender people
that is people who are suffering sexual
confusion are almost exactly the same
i don't really buy statistics generally
i don't really buy social science but
i'm more than happy to quote it when it
backs up my view and that's what's going
on here so even if their premise were
right
that
if rates of anxiety and depression and
suicide went down after mutilating your
body that therefore we should do it
even if that were right
it's
it it's not true in reality but but
furthermore what buddha judge is showing
here is an important issue that we've
got to confront on transgenderism
which is we can't split the baby on it
it's got to be all or nothing either
transgenderism is real and we've got to
endorse the surgeries or it's false
and it's not real and a man can't
secretly be a woman and our souls
actually do have something to do with
our bodies
and that's it because if transgenderism
is real
and if
the surgeries
can better help you to deal with your
gender dysphoria
then for sure we should do it in kids
right
if the idea is that puberty is is the
real cause of this discomfort or it
greatly accelerates the sexual
discomfort people have because
one is really a woman but then he takes
on all of these much more masculine
secondary sex characteristics then of
course you should put the kid on puberty
blockers
if if if the kid is really a woman
and by some quirk of biology he becomes
much more of a man then of course you
should stop that
so i there's a kind of
inner logic to the left's view on
transgenderism the problem is that the
premise is false because a man can't
secretly be a woman so you gotta reject
the whole thing okay and the squishes
need to need to stop trying to find some
conciliatory middle ground there's no
middle ground and the libs obviously
aren't going to stop they are now
presenting transiting the kids as though
it were the most common sense ordinary
thing and if you oppose transiting the
kids that you are some sort of horrible
bigot or some cynic political operative
rather than what you actually are which
is a person with at least a tenuous
slight grasp on reality unlike pete but
a judge unlike the entire left they're
not going to stop they're not going to
stop with adults can consenting adults
can do whatever they want an adult can
chop off his body parts if you want
they're not going to stop it's going to
go all the way down to little kids and
little toddlers and little babies
they're already doing that stand up now
people say well are you going to die on
this hill i don't intend to die on any
hill but if you don't stand up on a hill
and fight you're going to just
completely concede the whole battle
i'm glad you liked that clip now
ring the bell subscribe make sure you
get the notifications also head on over
to apple podcast but if i stitch your
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you